hey everyone how's it going today I'm
here with Jarvis and Charlie hey thanks
for being here yeah thanks for having us
[Laughter]
so today we're gonna be talking about
success now success is kind of like an
ambiguous fuzzy type of thing but I
consider you to be very successful this
is my house you know I thought we talked
about a little bit there's a lot of like
different definitions on what success is
and how you measure success so yeah I
thought I'd kind of like dig into what
you do so I wanted to first pose the
question how do you define success I can
start so I think about success as like
the agency and the freedom to pursue the
work that you want to do that is a
luxury that not everybody has and being
at that point is honestly like at least
one of the biggest pillars of success to
me and sort of to get into the Nitty
Gritty I think of success on like two
axes or two sides like the internal and
the external internal is like the pride
that you have in your own work like wow
I did a cool thing and I'm awesome and
the external is being recognized by your
peers and maybe your industry and I
think that you kind of need a mix of
both with just one it doesn't quite work
out yeah no I totally agree with that
group the agency thing and also this -
until next turn or thing right because
for me I have to be proud of the work
I'm doing but I also need what other
people to like be proud of me and
recognize that right because if I do
something that I love and no one else
recognizes it or no one else thinks it's
any good then I'm like oh this
I was wrong yeah and on the other side
it's someone else's that I've done
something really good and they're like
this is great work well done and I'm
like oh I don't think that's good so
you're wrong I think people make it seem
like it's very self-involved to be
externally validated or to have any of
those external factors in your success
no you should feel like yeah you just
you on your own is successful but I
don't buy into that at all I think it
like it's kind of like what you said
like they are nothing without each other
and it's you can have unhealthy balances
but they're do they have an important
role yeah and as humans I think we just
like want positive reinforcement like
that's part of our nature absolutely
that's like an important part of being
in a community we did not evolve in
isolation we evolved in civilization
together and I think that the need for
external validation is a natural side
effect yeah so for me it took a long
time to define like what does success
look like for me and I'm wondering like
how did you two come up with like how
you define success like was there like a
pivotal moment or a time in your life
where you realized what success was yeah
I think that as we were talking before
we were recording about how I was there
I was a nerd basically let's just put it
that way I was very good at school and I
say good at school because like I was
good at doing what was necessary to get
a good mark right it doesn't necessarily
mean you're a smart person it just means
you're good at playing the system yeah
but when you get out into the real world
like no one's giving you an A+ or a gold
star for doing your job
yeah there's things like bonuses and you
know like being praised in meetings and
stuff like that but you know being great
at is yeah I had to learn this internal
external validation thing yeah yeah I
had a very similar experience when I
graduated college I realized there
weren't gonna be any more moments where
like a big celebration happened right
and because of that it forced me to
re-evaluate some of the reward systems
that I'd built up a brand right that was
when I started to appreciate the journey
it's okay to have goals as you should
think of it like I love having goals and
striving towards them but the goal can't
just be the you can't not enjoy life
until you reach the goal that you want
because when you reach that goal it
won't make you happy it's really just
like a new guiding light it's like a new
direction to go down but if not for the
journey that gets you there it doesn't
mean anything
yeah absolutely yeah and like I actually
have to kind of you're two experiences
two of like after college you have I
think this is what they call almost like
a quarter life crisis we were just like
okay I'm done with school I went to
college now what because up until then
you're literally just like okay high
school gotta get good grades system yeah
good school get good grades get your
masters get your or get your bachelor's
and then get your first job yeah okay
now you have like 80 years left of your
life I'm gonna do it and then a lot of
cultures like in a lot of especially the
community that I grew up in it was like
okay now buy a house get married have
two and a half kids and a dog you know
and and now those are the other
checkpoints yeah when I when I graduated
I realized like what game I had been
playing this entire time it made me less
it made me want to sort of go my own way
and it made me think more broadly about
success yeah and I think that's when I
learned that agency side of things yeah
it was when there was no one like
feeding into validation is like the
checkpoints and grades and stuff yeah
yeah I learned that yeah I just need to
learn to be happy with what I'm doing
all the time like not just that one
moment right right so now that you two
have been out of college for a while and
you realize like how like what success
is how are some of the ways that you
measure like whether you're doing well
or not mine comes down now to which is
like the opposite from the grades and
things like that mine comes down now to
relationships building because the
people around us are really important
not just for that external validation
side of things but enriching us in
general it's people absolutely so I
focused my life now on like making
decisions on where am I gonna find my
people like where am I gonna find the
great conversations about smart people I
can learn from and like
yeah that's really awesome connection
with people is like one of the most
fulfilling part yeah and it's the most
interesting part of life yeah so that's
awesome that's fine and good but my
answer is cold hard cash I know money
equals life points when those go up
that's how you know you're successful no
I'm just kidding
that's not at all what I think so for me
I like to make these goals but I also
need to keep myself honest with them and
like track everything because when you
are iterating towards your eventual
destination it's very easy to not see
the forest for the trees yeah I like it
it so like when you are going to the gym
every day and like looking in the mirror
you don't see any of the games right but
when you go home first Thanksgiving
holiday or something like that and you
see a family member your uncle Jerry who
you haven't seen in like two years
he's like wow you look so different
you're like really and it's like yeah
here's a photo of us the last time we
saw you they'd be like well I'm a
completely different person and that's
like a physical manifestation but if
you're not keeping track of your own
stuff it's easy to lose sight of how far
you've come and then you can't even
appreciate that yes that growth because
then you're like oh I haven't done
anything it's like no you were a
completely different person in you
Brewin to something else and that is
valuable yeah sometimes I like to just
like sit and just have some me time and
like easily reflect like a year ago
today where was I I was actually just
reading your tweet on this or you know
like a year ago I was in a completely
different like place and now like Here I
am and I wouldn't have imagined yeah
yeah and I think it's important to
always be reflecting and like just be
proud of how far you've come but also
see like okay in a year in five years
from now like what's the general way or
path that I want to walk toward and I
think that those plans are like really
valuable to have but they're not like
strict rubrics anymore like school was
like the last stricter rubric that you
had and now maybe you have a five-year
plan that is that way and two years down
the road you realize you want to go that
that's not a failure yeah you've
gathered more information I think that
that is like the part of the journey
that we have to be more we have to be
cognizant that is kind of just like the
rest of life yeah yeah that's why I
think that you should set goals not
based on achieving a certain thing but
more like a certain state so like my
career goals when I was in university
was to work at a giant advertising
agency which is kind of the opposite of
what I do now and a small tech company
yeah and so if I was judging that it's
my goal and success
I failed right right but really what I
should have said my goal was was to like
be doing creative work be content with
what I'm doing be learning a life for it
it's make my decisions where I want to
write those are the goals that I think
you should aim for yeah and I think that
goal setting can be really hard
sometimes too because you really have to
figure out what's important to you like
that was something that I think over the
last two or three years that I really
understood like okay what is good goal
those are hard to set especially in life
but like through like asking about other
people's goals and asking you know like
what are the goals that you set for
yourself that you succeeded like are
really important questions to ask
yourself yeah yeah yeah when I was in
college I was like if I get a job at
Google game over yeah like it roll
credits
yeah like done and when I I didn't
internship there and then that like
information that's kind of an example of
like going somewhere and then realizing
like oh this isn't actually I I had this
dream that was based on very little
information and what it would actually
be like it was just like an achievement
it was a huge external one where a buddy
be like oh good job you did the thing
and now I work at a smaller company
where I have to keep explaining to
people what it is and if I was just
basing my success off of like the
external rain like do people recognize
the place that I work then I would be on
a completely different trajectory of my
life and I'm really happy with where I
am but we have to be open to our
perspective changing as we yeah grow
thank you so much for sharing with
your story this is really awesome I love
hearing about thanks for having us
we also did clouds on their channels so
Jarvis what are we doing your challenges
so in this video we talked about success
and in my video we're gonna be talking
about failure so mine is not so closely
tied in but these guards of developers
and I'm a design it and so yeah there we
go yeah that's the same way so their
channels and the collab links will be
posted in the description box below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up if you liked it and subscribe to my
channel I will see you next time pursue
you know
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]